COUNTRY.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Charles: IT IS AN INTERESTING
EXIST.
I WANT TO GET TO MY NEXT GUEST.
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
PRESIDENT, BRANDON JUDD.
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION NOW
FOR SO LONG YOU AND I.
THIS TWIST THAT BILL REFERRED
TO, SINGLE ADULT, GROWN MEN,
SUPPOSED TO BE EXPELLED INSTEAD
PUT IN TAXIS AND ON PLANES AND
DISBURSED AROUND THE COUNTRY.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN IS THAT?
>> YOU CAN'T EXPLAIN IT.
THAT'S WHY WE KNOW THE CRISIS IS
NOT GOING AWAY.
YOU ALLOWEDED THAT WE ALREADY
APPREHENDED MORE PEOPLE IN THIS
MONTH OF DECEMBER THAN WE HAD
THE PAST THREE DECEMBERS
COMBINED.
THAT IS SCARY TO ME BECAUSE
DECEMBER IS NORMALLY OUR SLOWEST
MONTH OF THE YEAR.
WHEN WE APPREHEND 178,000
PEOPLE, WHAT THAT IS SHOWING IS
THAT IT'S OVERWHELMING ALL
RESOURCES, NOT JUST CBP BUT
ICE'S RESOURCES.
WHEN I PROCESS PEOPLE FOR
DEPORTATION, I TURN THEM OVER TO
ICE.
ICE CAN EITHER HOLD THEM IN
CUSTODY, PENDING THAT
DEPORTATION PROCEEDING OR THEY
CAN RELEASE THEM WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO SHOW UP FOR THEIR COURT
PROCEEDINGS.
WHEN ICE GETS OVERWHELMED, WHEN
ICE DOESN'T HAVE THE SPACE TO
HOLD THEM, THAT'S WHAT WE SEE.
WHAT UPSETS ME ABOUT THIS, THE
ADMINISTRATION HIDES THIS FROM
EVERYBODY.
THEY DON'T TELL ANYBODY HOW MANY
PEOPLE ICE ARE RELEASING.
THEY SHOW HOW MANY PEOPLE CBP IS
RELEASING BUT THEY DON'T SHOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ICE ARE
RELEASING.
THAT'S WHERE THE HIDDEN NUMBER
COMES IN AND ALL OF THOSE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN FISCAL YEAR 21 WERE RELEASED
FROM ICE'S CUSTODY, NOT
NECESSARILY CBP.
>> Charles: YOU CAN SEE ICE IS
OVERWHELMED AND THEY SENT THEM
BACK.
BUT TO PUT THEM